dia la couverture mais ils bougent c'est
bien magnifique la maman quand vous
donnez un peu de mal fait un peu
maquillée coiffée vous faites un peu la
fille là c'est formidable bon c'est un
livre donc sur les coulisses du tennis
féminin et je vais vous faire une
interview vérité
bien d'un service très intéressant oui
vraiment pas ce qu'on apprend des trucs
alors là d'abord vous parlez du business
du business du tennis féminin et vous
relevé des choses tout à fait enfin une
fois qu'on les a lus dans votre bouquin
évidemment aux îles oui c'est vrai mais
bon il n'y avait pas pris conscience par
exemple qu'une fille comme martina
hingis soit photographiée par tous c'est
normal c'est la numéro deux mondiale
donc c'est normal qu'elle soit partout
et vous parler par exemple d'une fille
qui s'appelle anna kournikova qu'ils
aient jamais gagné un tournoi et qu'on
voit partout il ya des gros contrats de
sponsoring c'est à dire qu'en fait
finalement ce que vous dénoncez d'une
certaine façon dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le tennis féminin
bah ça commence à être plus le look que
le jeu oui c'est ça c'est ce que je
dénonce mais bon c'est bien pour un un
corner covage
ça me fait plaisir qu'elle gagne autant
parce qu'elle est sexy elle est jolie
c'est vrai mais je trouve que quand même
ce qui est important c'est qu'on regarde
le jeu des joueuses aussi quand les gens
viennent nous voir jouer on regarde
d'abord bon c'est vrai si elle est
mignonne tant mieux mais regardent ils
viennent voir jouer une joueuse quoi
alors vous y allez pas de main morte à
la balance ceci alors alors la cour
nicolas vous dit qu'un jour vous la
surprenait dans les vestiaires avec deux
portables un parent boyfriend
ça vous choque ça non ça me chante pas
ça me fait rigoler ouais penser qu'elle
a tort de elle joue avec ça en tout cas
elle joue beaucoup avec ça elle s'amuse
bien oui vous n'êtes pas jalouse pas du
tout alors toujours dans le business
vous vous annoncez vos gains qu'ils sont
en brut 1 9 million pour 98 par exemple
mais en fait après impôts les dépenses
de fonctionnement il vous reste deux
millions plus comme vous dites en fait
j'ai pas gagné ça toute ma vie donc il
faut que j'en profite parce que là c'est
enfin je sais pas si c'est votre
dernière saison ou pas on ne sait pas
encore mais en tous les cas ce ça risque
alors à par steffi graf et lindsay
davenport
tout le monde y passe dans votre bouquin
williams bouzid au moment d'entrer dans
le court monde entré sur le court pardon
elle vous regarde comme si vous étiez
une naine mais vous croyez pas que c'est
un jeu ça c'est comme à la boxe quand
mohamed hajji il dit à l'autre et
interminable je vais t'écraser non
classés c'est un jeu où on se regarde un
petit peu bizarrement dans les
vestiaires avant de rentrer même sur le
court au changement de côté on n'hésite
pas à bien se regarder dans les yeux et
à ceux d'hier maintient la prochaine
j'étais tu vas voir tu vas pas pouvoir
la voir quoi monica seles alors êtes
vous dit c'est un excédent est là un
excédent de bagages pour ton des alpes
où allez vous étonner à monica seles
monica seles allah a beaucoup apporté au
tennis parce que parce qu'elle est
arrivée elle prenait elle était
carrément dans le court elle prenait la
balle très tôt moi personnellement elle
a fait remettre en question mon jeu et
c'est grâce à elle aujourd'hui j'ai un
jeu très offensif
oui il y en a une qui est là où j'avais
pas de main morte c'est mary pierce vous
dit j'espère qu'elle s'arrête à la
créatine faut pas nous prendre pour des
imbéciles on sait bien que la créatine
ça peut masquer d'autres produits c'est
la vérité oui oui c'est la vérité mais
enfin ça y est comme toutes les vérités
pas tout le monde les exprime tout le
temps quoi non mais c'est bien mauresmo
vous lui reprochez enfin vous lui
reprochez rien du tout d'ailleurs mais
vous dites que c'est dommage que sa
petite amie soit devenu son entraîneur
parce qu'il faut pas mélanger
j-10 chacun sa place elle c'est vrai que
je trouve que si on a un coach sur le
circuit salines expliquer si on a bien
joué ma jouer je vois mal mon petit
copain venir me dis oh oui tu as joué
comme une brêle aujourd'hui extérieur
c'est pas son rôle
il est là plus tôt pour me consoler plus
tôt quand j'ai perdu et être sympa avec
moi quand j'ai gagné plutôt que vous
pensez qu'elle mélange un peu trop laid
justement en parlant de mauresmo
l'homosexualité dans le tennis féminin
c'est un mythe ou une réalité
bah pas puisque ailleurs ouais pas
puisque dans le monde en général
ouais pas plus que dans le tennis
masculin quoi chauffage du patron
d'antenne ce fils je sais pas je pense
sur dix joueuses il a combien qui soit
homosexuel pour voir 2 2 oui parce comme
partout alors comme ici ce soir autour
de cette table
bellemare il emmerde et là
à l'automne il a signé pour mer du nord
catherine meunier en colère maintenant
vous rendez vous en tout les cas on vous
a suspecté je dirais d'homosexualité
vous dites vous niez vous dit j'ai pas
de mec parce que je me suis contenté
enfin je me suis consacré à mon jeu et
si j'avais eu un mec c'est l'expression
j'ai répondu comme du sucre
donc c'est vrai vous avez en fait j'ai
sacrifié votre vie amoureuse au tennis
est vraiment le plateau phares ils
arrivent à vous placer alors qu'en ce
moment je suis en 1953 j'ai 47ans plus
elle pas sur vous poursuite deux ans non
mais c'est vous avez su vous avez mais
c'est fort comme s'est sacrifié votre
vie amoureuse si vous dites je suis pas
homosexuel bon c'est vrai qu'on voit
jamais qu'un garçon vision bois jamais
qu'un garçon c'est parce que je me
consacre au tennis pour moi jamais je
veux dire j'ai pas eu des petits copains
titrait pendant longtemps mais comme ça
mais puis j'ai pas envie de tout
mélanger quoi c'est tout alors il ya
parlé des vip où parlait aussi d'un
garçon senora alors là vous n'avez pas
de main morte non plus un nom je sais
pas moi j'ai lu le bouquin vous dites il
représente tout ce que j'ai toujours
combattu dans ma vie le travail à court
terme par à-coups enfin hold up et hop
là parce que je pense que yannick aurait
pu faire une carrière way meilleur je
n'avais pas fait de ce qu il a fait quoi
mais un peu comme mauresmo c'est des
gens qui s'éclate en jouant ouais c'est
ça mais moi aussi je lui ai mis un jouet
mais vous n'êtes pas un peu plus light
vous non voilà voilà
eux ils s'éclatent en jouant tous se
marrer quoi alors que vous vous êtes
plus rigoristes d'une certaine façon
bourreuse ouais mais vous dites j'ai lu
dans un journal cette semaine dans le
magazine vous est il est inabordable
non pour moi oui là ça a été dur de
couper à tous et où on n'a pas su c'est
peut-être de ma faute aussi j'ai
peut-être su
ben c'est bien communiquer avec lui
alors le tennis féminin vous dites donc
c'est plus en plus sexy donc c'est plus
en plus le look la beauté les love story
les scandales les critères athlétiques
disparaissent au profit des critères
esthétiques
c'est quoi la commune malte liste oui la
commune de man blessés quand vous faites
partie des 20 meilleures joueuses du
monde
les directeurs de tendre choisissent les
meilleures joueuses qui veulent avoir
dans leur tournoi dont qui font 20 voilà
nous on aimerait avoir une guide
d'avesnes fort dans quel plus il ya deux
directeurs de tournois qui ne veulent
plus se rend au delà liste quoi mais en
fait c'est rien à voir avec le
classement atp en fait c'était wta pour
vous oui mais c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est un en fait c'est un
classement sans le joug que c'est pas un
classement sur les sur les qualités
sportives sur les ventes de billets
coisy mme kane de billets ou qu'on est
qu'obama plus vente de billets que que
julie halard ou comme da voilà donc moi
je suis 5e mondiale et sur cette liste
suit 16e quoi sauf quand ils auront vu
ça la faisait les premières là sur leur
manque le petit bout de magnéto qu'on a
vu que la couverture du livre à mon avis
que vous n'allez pas sur le court comme
ça vous aurez répond numéro anne lacaud
mythomane liste on vous dit
vous dites donc le tennis féminin est de
plus en plus sexy un sas pour viens de
dire est toujours aussi sexiste
c'est à dire que les garçons ça j'ai
aussi appris ça en lisant un bouquin son
pays deux fois plus que vous deux fois
plus sur le sur le circuit en général
oui mais dans les grands chelems n'ont
quand même pas tout à fait un gain on se
rapproche de plus en plus du prize money
des garçons mais c'est pas ça encore
donc c'est vrai qu'on demande
aujourd'hui on demande des joueuses on
demande à voir égalité de prix du moins
dans les grands chelems normal parce que
le tennis et des femmes et parfois plus
intéressant que les que les hommes si on
nous dira qu'il payerait les il payerait
les ordres à la vitesse de la balle en
fait oui oui c'est ça alors que lindsay
jupette par les grands chelems on nous
dit ouais mais les garçons jouent 5,7 et
vous enjouer que trois mais bon au
niveau de télévision aujourd'hui
ouais on est au dessus quoi bon enfin
tous les cas c'est un livre très
intéressant que je recommande à nos amis
l'on sait chez plon les dessous du
tennis féminin par nathalie tauziat et
maintenant après tout ça on va vous voir
jouer